we've had written history for 5,000
years
right people have been generally
literate for less than 500 years but
we've had culture for 150,000 years
identifiable culture for at least 25,000
so the vast period of our inculturation
was preliterate inculturation before we
could write down the rules and transmit
them how are they transmitted assuming
we had culture well there's a variety of
mechanisms we have a tendency to see
elements of the world in personified
form because most of the
interrelationships we have with the
world are actually social or
interpersonal relationships so that's
basically how our brain is structured
and as we evolved we develop the
capacity to extend our cognitive ability
beyond the merely social to take in the
world as such but the categories that we
use to do that we're still fundamentally
social now the reason the unknown per se
is symbolized as feminine is because the
critical feature of the feminine and I
don't mean the female individual I mean
the feminine as a category is its
capacity to generate new forms and the
unknown as such is is logically and
appropriately symbolized by the feminine
because it's the bringer fourth of all
things which is to say that the
background of existence the unknowable
background of existence is the thing
that generates everything paired with
that of course according to the schema
that we've been working with is the
archetype of the Great Father and the
archetype of the Great Father is the
archetype of tradition fundamentally the
great weight of the past because as you
incorporate your past the past of your
culture through the intermediation of
your parents you learn routines and
rituals for structuring the unknown now
those are routines and rituals are
patterns of action that you use in the
world as such and also complex patterns
of action that you use to structure your
own interpretations and your own motor
output in your own conceptualizations
when you're dealing with other people
and so that would be the absorption fund
most fundamentally of your cultural
rules
and the fact of those cultural rules and
their incarnation in you essentially
keeps chaos at bay which means if two of
you share the same cultural structure
assuming you're playing the same game so
to speak that means that you can each
predict each other's responses which is
very very useful because that way you
you can be sure that you can trust the
other person you can more or less infer
their goals because after all their
value structure of similar to yours and
if you can infer their goals that means
you can embody their emotions so that's
the benevolent aspect of tradition right
the part that protects and shelters you
and structures the nature of your being
in the face of existential terror and
doubt so to speak but there's also an
aspect of tradition that's terrible
tyrannical it's the part that marches
young men off to war say in defense of
the structures that it's protecting it's
the part that says when you're a
teenager wear this and not this or
you'll be the target of mockery for all
your peers it's the part of the
structure that crushes the creative life
out of you because the tyrannical aspect
of social order doesn't want your
creative light life so to speak what it
wants is your obedience because your
obedience is what makes the Machine run
smooth and so you're always in an
ambivalent relationship with regards to
security to Authority on the one hand it
provides you shelter and what you need
and allows you to gain the benefits of
literally thousands and thousands of
years of cultural evolution on the other
hand it's the thing that makes you obey
or face the painful consequences thereof
which can range from you know mere
social exclusion and consequent re
exposure to the unknown to truly
oppressive practices designed to make
you be exactly like everyone else or
else and so you could say most
particularly again that that's a
standard existential problem it's a
problem that's faced by people in every
place and in every culture balancing the
appropriate attitude towards culture
so the most fundamental representation
of culture can be portrayed essentially
in this manner I think and what you see
here is the dragon of chaos of course
lurking in the background and what that
means is that all forms come from the
formless and that the farther itself is
a primary form representation of God the
Father and God the Father in the
Christian Trinity is the representation
of the positive and the security
inducing and the tyrannical aspect of
social order right God has a set of
rules for you you bloody well better
listen to those rules if you don't all
hell is going to break loose and you
know that's a pretty reasonable summary
of how things work unfortunately so on
the one hand God offers security on the
other hand he offers tyranny and in
total that basically represents order so
you can see this representation is quite
useful shows God's standing over this
city which of course is a city committed
to him fundamentally so it operates
under the moral principles that he
represents and behind him is a
representation of the son which is
partly a representation of the source of
all life partly a representation of the
source of consciousness and illumination
right because you're conscious during
the day and partly a a halo representing
the sort of transcendent nature of the
of the social order that structures
existence so it's a primary phenomenon
and it's only to say that in all human
experience there's a cultural aspect and
a natural aspect and the funny thing is
the cultural aspect in some ways is as
natural as the natural aspect right
because we're social beings we can't
exist without society society structures
our very nature
then it were beneficiaries and victims
and so then just as the case just as is
the case with the feminine there's a two
aspects that can be represented
metaphorically with regards to the
masculine you can say well the secure
aspect of social order is the wise King
and you can see a writ medieval
representation of him they're sitting on
his throne calmly in a relatively open
posture that means he's ready to listen
to supplicants to people who are coming
to talk to him he's holding an orb with
a cross on top of it which means
essentially that he's in control of the
world and that the world is subordinated
to something else that's represented by
the cross a wise and just ruler and then
his mirror image here is the Sun
devouring King a very common
mythological theme the father who wants
to destroy his son and the shades of the
eatable conflict in that of course if
you remember your Freud but basically
what it means is this is that despite
the fact that every human being is an
offspring of culture by nature every
human being is also in the terrible
position of facing the fact that they're
very individuality is likely to be
crushed out of them during during the
socialization process and that in a
sense that's really not in that's really
not avoidable I mean if you're subject
to really tyrannical socialization it's
obviously a much more Cardinal problem
right but even if you're subject to
socialization under normal circumstances
you are still what you are rather than
the many fold things that you could have
otherwise been and and and just to give
you some sense of how dramatic a process
this really is one of the things you
should know is that you actually die
into your brain so one of the things you
might wonder is why is why is it the
death evolved it doesn't really make
that much sense from a Darwinian
perspective right because you'd make the
presupposition that if you could just
stick around and farther children say
for 250 years you'd be doing a lot
better job than the poor sap who only
lived to be thirty so why is it that you
only live to be 70 and really you're you
know your period of fertility is over
say by the time you're 40 why would that
be what's the utility of death and then
you remember well
the environments always changing right
in this chaotic manner that's
represented by the great mother
can you change with it and the answer to
that is yes but only to a certain point
which is why as people age they stay
tend to become more and more alienated
from the current culture right they've
they've adopted their position of being
say which is a more or less fixed by the
time they're 25 or so once their
prefrontal cortex matures and then after
that the world gets away from they don't
have enough biological resources left to
constantly undergo new revolutionary
neurological processes and part of the
reason is this you have more neural
connections in your brain when you're
first born than you do for the rest of
your life any other time in your life
and as you learn when you're an infant
and as you learn say over the first two
years what happens is that there's a
plenitude of circuits and they die off
leaving only those circuits that have a
function and you think about that it's
kind of a quasi Darwinian process and so
what that means is that as you mature
and become fixed in your form you know
to adopt your personality whatever it
becomes what's happening is that the
excess possibility in some sense is
being demolished by experience so the
tyrannical aspect of enculturation is
something that's real because it makes
you in large part what you are and you
have to understand as well that that's
necessary because it's better to be
something in the final analysis it's
better to be something than to be
nothing but you know we still have
residual dreams like those expressed by
Peter Pan say who's the boy that never
wants to grow up because he doesn't want
to attain any final and fixed form and
it's interesting because in one respect
as you progress through your life you're
climbing assuming things are going well
you're climbing to ever new heights but
on the other hand the the direction that
you're going in constantly narrows as
you age so there's a real trade-off
there and I think the existential angst
that's caused as a consequence of that
trade-off is often real and I also think
that adolescents and early adults feel
this most intently which is part of the
reason why they tend to
rebel against social structures in
general you know the whether it's the
military-industrial complex or the
corporate world or globalization or
what-have-you is that you have these
large structures that represent the
tyrannical aspect of social being and
and it's no wonder that the fact of
those structures engenders rebellion it
should on the other hand it's also no
wonder that structures like that exist
because if they didn't exist then people
would have no way of inter relating
their their social being and we would
revert back to the sort of Hobbesian
state of war where everybody's arms are
around everybody else's throat that
doesn't mean the payoff is always good
so for the Freudians of course had a
real field day with this and we're most
fundamentally concerned by it now part
of the reason that Freudian psychology
has had such an immense impact on
Western and world cultures because Freud
came along just when classical
judeo-christian mythological structures
were on on a serious decline in the West
and Freud stepped in with a secularized
mythological version of reality which
said well there's nature that's the end
right that's the wild and untamed
impulses that spring up from from the
animal mind and there's the ego which is
the individual who's in many ways a pawn
of these it'd like forces and then on
top of the ego crushing it down into the
edge so to speak is the super-ego which
is the internal and external embodiment
of social order and morality so you can
see the mythological sub structure
underlying Freud for it said well the
ego is always being shaped by the
super-ego and it's always compulsion
it's don't don't it's always no it's
like old testament morality right in the
incarnation of the Ten Commandments
whatever you want to do if it feels good
the probability is high that it's
immoral from the perspective of the
social world and you can really see this
with children you know it's really
remarkable to watch them because my
sense is and I don't think this is just
because I'm a particularly tyrannical
father is that children often get in
more trouble for having fun than they do
for any other reason because their
capacity for unbridled enjoyment is so
unbridled that it actually poses a
threat to orderly structure so
you know if a child really gets in an
active mood and is playing a very active
game I mean especially if they're
somewhere between say 3 and 5 they can
tear your house to shreds and no times
no time flat you're always falling
around going no no no quiet down don't
do that and you know they're smiling
away and they're happier than any adult
you're ever going to see in your entire
life and you're doing everything you can
to push them down so that they're they
can sit quietly and read a book or
whatever it is you think they should be
doing and that's really nasty and
horrible but by the same token it's
absolutely necessary because if they
don't learn to bring their impulses even
their impulses their ludecke impulses
right their impulses to play under
control then nobody else can stand them
and if they don't get access to the
resources that are in the social world
man they have one dismal life laid out
in front of them so anyway so that's an
early description of the genesis of the
conflict say between the ego and the
super-ego and I just wanted to point
that out because it's not just sex and
aggression that gets regulated right I
mean we can understand why that might
happen but it's also playfulness and
creativity and spontaneity and all the
things that we associated with the joy
of being that the terrible tyrannical
social structure puts a clamp on so Jack
panksepp for example has recently
demonstrated that children boys because
it's usually boys who have attention
deficit disorder which is generally
diagnosed in the schoolroom do much
better if they're placed on
methylphenidate which is a kind of
amphetamine fundamentally but normal
kids do better on amphetamines too by
the way they can folk better they can
focus more and they can pay attention
more mostly what methylphenidate does is
suppress play so peg steps notion is
that while what's happening with these
ADHD kids hyperactive kids is they're
more playful more boisterously playful
which is tends to be a masculine
attribute in in the juvenile forms of
many mammals they're boisterously
playful give them a little
methylphenidate that shuts down their
play behavior and they can sit down and
focus you know and well you can
understand how even if you might think
that's necessary because apparently many
people do you can also still understand
that by the same token that probably
represents some kind of loss right
because we like to see kids play and
it's good for them besides so anyways
Freud says
the ego pops up its all thrilled to
death with the world the super-ego comes
along and shuts it down and that's a
fate that befalls all of us and not only
that because Freud's a pretty wise man
all things considered he doesn't say
that's all to the bat he says that's the
price we pay for social being and fair
enough
you see this happening in children all
the time we're part of what they do as
they mature is to adopt rules so they'll
play being a father or being a mother
say and what they're doing is pulling in
what they see as the worldview that
characterizes parenthood embodying the
farther playing out the role and trying
to organize their motivational
structures within the observed framework
say that the father provides and that's
an interjection of social wisdom if you
can imagine that the role of fathers say
has a structure like one structure would
be well if you're a father and you're
around to model then you have to be
taking care of the children or at least
you have to be there often enough so
that you can be a target of modeling and
so you can imagine that the spirit of
the father that's modeled at least in
the optimal circumstances is one that
deals out rules in order but that also
provides nurturing care and support and
that's a kind of story we know fathers
who aren't like that and maybe we know
fathers who are too much like that but
all things considered on the average you
have a father role and children attempt
to intimidate their own motivation
resources so for example if the child
observes the farther and the mother
sharing which means taking each other's
motivational states into account then
they can act out the game of sharing
with a doll say representing a child and
what they're doing is trying to imagine
what it's like inside that doll's head
treating it like a person by embodying
the potential motivations and emotional
states of that pretend object in their
own body and then by trying to organize
a higher order structure which would be
like the Tea Party where tea is shared a
higher order structure where you have a
turn because you want to turn because
you're thirsty like me and then I have a
turn and we both get what we want and we
can exchange information and well
that's a little bit more optimistic
representation of the tyranny of social
order than pure compulsion right because
what it suggests is there's a way that
you can organize the way you are
genuinely and the way I am genuinely so
that we both are genuine yet we get
something more than we would get if we
were just by ourselves and so you think
that with kids they like to play by
themselves but by the time they're about
three and a half or four boy like they
have a hunger for other children and
they'll do anything in order to go out
and play with other kids so you can say
to them well if you if you take all the
toys off your bed I'll go and let you
play with your friend and like the toys
are off there in two tenths of a second
and they're out the door because they
have this primary need to go out and
experiment with the social world and in
large way in large part that's how they
build the complex higher order more
abstract structures that enable them to
regulate their motivate their
motivational states and their emotional
states without just no it's it's a more
sophisticated way of doing it right it's
better to play a game with someone than
to engage in a battle of wills with them
because then there's no compulsion
there's just mutual participation and
that's critical because one of the
things that the notion of the tyranny of
the social order brings up as a question
is all right all right so you have to
take part in society right you have to
take your part in the social world yet
the social world wants its pound of
flesh or it's 60 pounds of flesh
depending on where you live on the one
so you're damned if you do so to speak
and you're damned if you don't what do
you do as a consequence of facing that
challenge and so you remember with the
great mother with chaos and the unknown
the way you meet the challenge is to
understand that the things you don't
understand are dangerous and frightening
and that if you encounter them they can
hurt you and that this is real but you
don't run away all the same right if
you're trying to get somewhere and
things you don't understand happen you
can't shut yourself down you have to
explore cautiously and try to gain new
knowledge
how do you organize your social being
well let's make the presupposition that
you've got half a dozen or so
fundamental motivational states right so
what they are is your subjugation to a
world of a priori deities right you see
in children rage fear hunger anger
affiliation love the capacity to play
all value sets which have their own goal
like behavioral patterns their own
worldview their own way of manifesting
themselves all those are innate right
they're all dependent on pre-wired
neural architectural systems they have
to unfold in experience but they're
there ok and so let's say that's what
you come into the world with and that's
what you come into the world with and
that's what you come into the world with
but then the fact that you're in the
world poses a more complex problem which
is well yeah you've got one motivational
state happening you're angry but then
you've got another one you have to worry
about which is you'd like to be
affiliated with someone like your
sibling so you got a real conflict with
your sibling it's like you really hate
them but you really like them too and
you want to play with them so what do
you do about that well you'd say a
behaviorally dysregulated child who
isn't well socialized they're impulsive
they don't they don't act as if they
take the future into account so they
heavily future discount they're
impulsive what does that mean if you
watch a child have a temper tantrum
which around - they're really prone to
it's like it's a phenomena you know it's
like a tornado on a real small scale the
child's just flipped out if you saw an
adult do that you'd run away screaming
right and they're completely dominated
by this emotional state and my sense
watching that is always being to kind of
try to help the kid not have that happen
to them because it looks like a terrible
catastrophe for their emerging ego right
I mean they're trying to get their world
together and something frustrates them
and whomp up companies like the amygdala
projections that are governing anger
hypothalamic even more primitive and
just like pull them over and then
they're on the floor and they're holding
their breath and they're turning blue
and
having a fit and then it takes them like
15 minutes to recover so they have to
take themselves into account as total as
complete beings and that's the emergence
of a higher order morality but it's more
complicated than that because not only
do they have the problem of themselves
which is a bad enough problem but then
they have the problem of the other
person so what's the proper response of
the individual given that he or she is
threatened by the natural world and the
unknown on the left-hand and threatened
by the social order and it's tyranny on
the right hand but also dependent on the
natural world and chaos for all good
things and all new information and
dependent on the social order for their
very mode of being right caught between
four paradoxes all at the same time how
can that route be properly negotiated
well then you can look at hero mythology
and the most common plot and I would say
in some ways the only plot although
there are variations of this that are
endless romantic variations or adventure
story variations or variations of failed
heroic endeavor still the only plot goes
something like this there's a current
state of being now that can be
represented by a psychological state
your current personality it can be
represented by your family it can be
represented by your extended social
group your city your town your country
your ecosystem your your your in science
fiction frequently the entire global
community right a structure is
threatened by what well you name it if
it's dangerous it can threaten the
structure that can be one of various
forms of barbarian right any person from
another culture an alien in science
fiction a terrible monster that lives in
the deep that had been dominated and
oppressed before but has come back for
more an agent of horror that's a common
theme in modern horror movies right an
object that moves the ghosts in the
basement because the dead were
improperly buried etc etc etc anything
uncanny anything fear-inspiring and
thing reptilian anything that smothers
or in trances or seduces or you name it
if it's change or some metaphoric
representation of anything that can
change then it's this the dragon of
chaos and that's the thing that always
threatens the stable state in its
multiple potential manifest forms and
what does that mean
it means the apocalypse is always
happening right the end of the world is
always before us which is why you see
apocalyptic imagery for example
throughout the New Testament Christ says
the world is coming to an end and people
are waiting around for it to happen but
what they don't precisely understand is
that the world is always coming to an
end always and that's because what you
think now is not good enough for the
next second right you have to change
because change is coming and what change
means is you have to let go of what you
know that's the apocalypse and it's
always on us this structure is
threatened what do you do about that
well you can run but you can't hide
right that's the theory and the reason
for that is that even if you are
unwilling to face the threat that's
right in front of you no matter where
you run to that threats going to be
there so you see in the case of an
agoraphobic woman who starts to run away
from the shopping mall when she has
heart palpitations that then she runs
away from the subway and then she runs
away from taxis and then buses and then
other people then finally she's at home
and there's nowhere to run but her heart
still palpitating and the fear of death
is still on her and there's no place to
go so hiding isn't much of a help or you
can pretend that the chaotic thing isn't
there and refused to change but all that
does is make the threat bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger so just
like simply put well say you only have a
hundred dollars in the bank and you have
a hundred and ten dollar telephone bill
and you think well I
I'd like that hundred dollars I'm not
going to pay that telephone bill it's
just a little threat right but then you
don't pay it in the next month it's $125
telephone bill and then they slap a
fifty dollar charge on you and then they
cut off your phone so then you don't
have a phone
then you miss a job appointment and
that's not so good and then it's two
hundred and fifty dollars to pay your
phone bill and another 200 to get it
hooked back up then your credit record
goes all to hell because you haven't
paid any of that then you can't buy a
house when you're 25 and you think kind
of weird a little bitty chaos turns into
a great big monster and partly that's
because everything that looks separate
from everything else isn't it just looks
that way and when you ignore anything
especially if it's impeding your
progress you know it's impeding your
progress you know you have to deal with
it step away from it and see what it's
true nature really is so you can hide
and you cannot change or you can pretend
that the threat doesn't exist but in the
final analysis that just stores up the
catastrophe for later
you